that's that's good I was planning on
shooting my brains so heavy you could
injure someone with this isn't this
heavy this is a weapon
this is a weapon of mass destruction
it's the world's largest gummy bear are
you gonna make us eat this there's 51
thirds 51 servings of gummy bears
this looks like it contains the soul of
a child o mine oh it really smells like
that really grows cough medicine you get
as a child it doesn't feel like a normal
gummy bear it's much more
it feels like silicone are you going for
the head first or the buffers hmm oh my
god I just started with the ear I think
that'll be an easier way to lunch group
oh no that was a bad idea I can almost
hear it screaming right now I honestly
don't feel bad though like he deserves
this I heard my job yeah workman's comp
for gummy bear injuries it's so thick
this is a steak house [ __ ] I guess I'll
bite its crotch mad good okay I just
want to love him and care for him after
you mauled its face yeah I feel like a
monster I'm so sorry I wanna rub its
tummy oh my god it's gonna change my
poop into blue like no I was imagining
poop and it's like the little actual gum
it tastes like pain like numbness
honestly it could be anything right now
I could I really could just be eating
flesh right now because it has that
consistency if you tried flesh
I guess we'll never know but this is not
real food this is something the
government needs to put children in
second so gummy bears are no government
conspiracy come I feel like the gummy
bears he's won I don't think I ever won
any gummies ever again my mouth is
stained with the blood of my enemies let
this be a warning okay like slides down
your whole body and probably out your
butthole right away
[Music]